we talked last week about Jada pinket
Smith and her NeverEnding Will Smith
humiliation tour which has been uh
kicked into a new gear recently with the
release of her Memoir and in the
Memoir she reveals even more
embarrassing things about Will Smith
including the fact that she um left him
in 2016 after so she was the one who
cheated on him and then uh the marriage
broke up and I it's at least heavily
implied that she's the one who broke it
up and so then that leads to the
conclusion that Will Smith on the when
he did the infamous slap of Chris Rock
he was doing that in defense of a woman
who's not even who's not even living
with him anymore and it hadn't been for
years which is even more embarrassing so
she brought that out to embarrass him
again and now we have uh Will Smith's
response to all of this so the New York
Post Has This Will Smith has broken his
silence about the Bombshells dropped by
his estranged wife Jada pinket Smith
about their 25-year marriage the Men in
Black Star 55 sent to new York Times an
email saying the revelations kind of
woke him up adding that pinket Smith 52
was more quote resilient clever and
compassionate than he'd understood quote
when you've been with someone uh for
more than half of your life a sort of
emotional blindness sets in Smith wrote
according to the Times article published
Saturday and you and you can all too
easily lose your sensitivity to their
hidden nuances and subtle
beauties that was Will Smith's response
so after being publicly humiliated Again
by his apparently estranged wife he
responds by blaming
himself and his emotional blindness so
he's the one who's emotionally
blind she is just ripping him the shreds
in public constantly no concern for his
own emotions that she's the one who
brings him on camera to talk about her
affair while he sits there clearly like
on the verge of tears it's an utter l ly
Broken Man and she doesn't notice or
doesn't care or both um and yet Will
Smith says that he's the one who is
emotionally blind and then he extols
Jada's hidden nuances and subtle
Beauties and it's true by the way I
don't deny that if Jada pinket Smith has
any beauty it is very subtle very very
subtle if there's Beauty there it is
extremely it's so subtle that it's
invisible it's so subtle that it doesn't
exist
that nobody can find it but this is how
he responds and it's it's
why uh to my point last week about this
it's why Will Smith um know is not a
victim and I think that's an important
point because it seems like the public
is mostly against Jada pinket Smith um
OD you know maybe surprisingly enough
this is this is this based on what I've
seen this may be the only bipartisan
issue left in America this might be the
only thing left that everybody agrees on
on all sides of of uh every side of of
the of our fractured
culture everyone seems to agree that
Jada pingin Smith is an awful
witch um so in a in a weird way she's
like bringing the country
together so that everyone can just hate
her so that that's kind of a service
that she's providing maybe we should
thank her for it maybe that's the hidden
nuance and subtle beauty that Will Smith
was talking about but and and far be for
me to um you know try
to when we have this kind of unity I I
would like to join in but I but I would
like to say that I think it sometimes it
goes too far on the other end where
people talk about Will Smith like he's
some sort of helpless victim who's in
this abusive marriage but what we see is
that he's not a victim at all really I
mean JD ping Smith is an awful witch no
question about it but Will Smith is a
willing participant in his own
humiliation and
degradation and uh uh I do hold him
responsible for
that and now he's encouraging his
estranged wife to embarrass him even
more and respect him even
less by responding in a way that is not
respectable so J B Smith is going to see
his response and just despise him even
more and have even less respect for him
which is not a defense of
her but um it it also just goes to show
why Will Smith is not a victim and this
is this
is like we talked about last week you
know respect in a
marriage is not just important it's is
foundational and especially for the man
the man has to feel respected in a
marriage he has to be respected in his
marriage and if there's no respect in
the marriage then it then it's a recipe
for for total collapse and
disaster every bad thing that can happen
in a marriage can will happen from from
that starting point that's where you get
into infidelity and everything else
often times it begins there with a with
a lack of respect people always say
happy dog happy life you hear it all the
time well if that's really the case you
need to be giving your dog rough greens
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
before I started feeding my dog rough
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jump start
trial bag can be at your door in just a
few business days so go to Ru greens.com
mat or call 844 ru700 that's Ruff
greens.com mat or call 844 Ru 700 today
there there's a calling on both ends
here so the the wife has called it is
her Duty and her responsibility to
respect her husband and treat her
husband with
respect um and she has that
responsibility regardless like there's
it's it's not okay to disrespect your
husband to treat him with
contempt um and you have a
responsibility to respect your husband
on the other on the other hand on the
other not on the other hand but on the
other end of it uh the husband also has
a responsibility to be
respectable and to not just respectable
but to command respect and there is a
difference I think last week when we
talked about this I said that Will Smith
should demand respect in his home or
should have it's probably too late for
they don't even live in the same home
anymore but long ago he should have
demanded respect in his household and if
he had maybe things would be different
now you know
um but I think demand is the wrong word
because if you if you get to the point
where you're demanding that's already
that that's a sign of weakness if you
have to demand it I want to be respected
respect
me um now if you feel that you need to
Express that and say it out loud then
you should but that's already a sign
that things are not going well and it's
a sign of of it can be a sign of
desperation and weakness on your end uh
what you should be doing as a man in
your home is commanding respect so you
don't have to say it but you're
commanding with your with your presence
in the home and the way you conduct
yourself you command
it um and it's clear that Will Smith
never did
so no excuse for Jada pinket Smith at
all no excuse for Will
Smith this is just one of those
situations in so many cases when
marriages fall apart like this you know
sometimes you can point to one person
and say well that person's clearly the
bad guy it's all their fault but most of
the time uh you can you can look at at
both sides and say you know it's it's
it's obvious what you did wrong here so
I that's the case here hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there